Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So you made a fifteen part video that I responded
to with a sixteen part video because I thought
your video had sixteen parts.
And then you made another fifteen part video.
So here are sixteen things I love about being
outside.
Now Hank, as you know I am a long time opponent
of outside.
Our ancestors made extraordinary sacrifices
for millennia to create inside.
And then we just dishonor all of that work
by willfully going outside.
But that noted, there is a lot I like about
being outside.
Beginning with the irregularly shaped polygons
that the sky forms through the trees.
I love daddy long legs.
How is a creature like you even real?
This honeysuckle tree is invasive and horrible
but I love the way it bends toward the light.
I love the mighty White River here in Indianapolis.
So Hank, Indianapolis was created by politicians
who wanted to put the capital city of Indiana
in the geographical middle of Indiana.
And they were like "Oh that place looks good
it's on the banks of the mighty White River.
And that was important in the early nineteenth
century, you had to be on some kind of navigable
waterway to like, get stuff to your town.
But it turns out, that in many places the
White River is like six inches deep, which
is how Indianapolis came to be the largest
American city not on a navigable waterway!
I love geese and their little goslings, I
also love Ryan Gosling but that's a different
video.
I love that downy woodpecker that's in there
somewhere.
I love turtles.
Bye turtle!
Sorry if I scared you.
I love flowers.
Contemporary flowers are like a collaboration
among humans and plants and bees.
Boy, Hank do we need to collaborate better
with plants and bees.
I love bubbles and they're just not the same
inside.
I love peeing outside.
For the record I'm not doing it right now.
I'm just saying I love that feeling, it's
like "I too am an animal!"
I love like weird swamps that feel undiscovered,
they make me feel like an explorer.
I love snails.
Also, while I have great admiration for the
hardworking chemistry majors in the artificial
smell business, there's nothing quite like
the actual smell of outside.
I know I'm starting to sound like the nature
enthusiasts I've always reviled but these
leaves just smell so good!
I just got a mosquito bite on my cheek and
now I probably have West Nile virus so thanks
mosquitoes, for reminding me what I don't
love about outside.
I love how like when I'm looking for coyotes
and great blue herons and all that kind of
stuff sometimes I'll just see Henry and he'll
be like "Dad, Dad, Dad, look at this moss!!"
He and Alice always remind me that with the
right level of attentiveness, everything is
amazing.
I love tiny little trees.
The forest is big and mostly without light
and you probably won't make it, tiny little
tree, but I wish you luck!
I love trees that lean out over the water.
They're doomed but they keep going.
I guess most of what I like about nature Hank,
is its ability to go on, no matter what.
I find that quite inspirational.
I'll see you on Friday.
Oh.
Gah, ruined a perfectly good outro, this guy.
Stupid nature always tripping me.